so this is important because
we've released a lot of videos on islam
i've been put on care's watch list
we've had to beef up security people
know this muslims inherently aren't very
peaceful now
the biggest islamic youtube channel that
i know of is talk
islam this is a huge youtube channel
this man has gone after me specifically
claiming that i'm wrong rebutting some
of the claims that i've made
and uh while he's refused of course to
come on the program
and he often he's the guy who's held out
as
the moderate muslim he's he's he's
reforming islam
he did nothing to do with my prophet
saying none of these things have to do
with my prophet the veil
never really condemnation of terrorism
so i had my wonderful you know i do
research but i also have some wonderful
people i can't take credit for it
r is his code name thank you r very much
for helping with this
since talk islam has gone after me and
refused to come on the program
we decided to do some research moderate
islam
what does that mean exactly here's what
we found out so
talk islam is a youtube channel their
biggest link
they don't operate on their own i knew
that and it seems that their greatest
partnership
is with an organization called the iera
era is what we'll use from
from now on era uh they've worked this
to talk islam
they've claimed credit for this guy over
at talk islam
uh his name is kamal saleh he does
spoken word so they've talked about him
they've taken credit for him
and he has had members
of the ira on his network members you
can see right here if you're listening
to wrestling videos where they're very
friendly
they're very chummy they've even hosted
each other on each other's websites
and they've spoken on the same podiums
doing events
together there has been a lot of cross
promotion between talk islam
and era the iera network there you go
you can see them right there on their
website i believe that era is what
sustained the talk islam channel now it
matters
what does ira believe
uh well let's start let's go in in order
of increasing
disturbingness okay uh how does era
where do they line up on wife beating
these moderate muslims who work
with talk islam well guess what one of
their founding members
green said it's okay for men to beat
their wives
nothing to do with their prophet well
the organization that they work with
says
yeah it's cool to beat your wives so
that's we're going we're going in
ascending order here
uh they also support the killing of
adulterers adulterer i guess more so
adulteresses
uh they're big on that this is era
they've supported the death of
adulterers despite the fact that one of
the founding
members um was caught in an ashley
madison hack
that guy zortsy who you just saw in the
previous video who was on with talk
islam
he actually it wasn't just his name
there he had a credit card so they
advocate death for adulterers wife
beating even though they were directly
involved with the mad
ashley madison hack where they line up
on we've talked about this muhammad
raping his nine-year-old wife aisha
married when she was six
raped her when she was nine that would
seem relatively extreme again we're
going in order here we're building a
case
where does era and talk islam where do
they line up
on raping your nine-year-old wife well
they support it if it meets
these conditions we have a video this is
our law it's nothing to do with aids now
listen to the principles
if we're principled number one is she
physically fit
number two is she emotionally ready
number three
is she mentally ready number four is it
socially acceptable
number five all of these different kind
of principles that we apply
and it happened that there's an outlier
from the statistics that a nine-year-old
was physically fit was mentally ready
was
uh even given away by her own father and
her tribe so they support the raping of
a nine-year-old this is not extreme
okay these are the moderate muslims out
there these are the ones with the
biggest
talk islam youtube channel in existence
these are the best that they have to
offer
these are the huffpo the salon the slate
muslims
uh let's get to something else okay you
would think right they of course they
hate terrorism of course they would
condemn terrorism hashtag not all
muslims
well at these events where they speak
these summits
there have been representatives of er
let me make sure i get this this
gentleman's name
right hussein yi hussein ye
over there who appeared alongside talk
islam at one of these summits uh were
they line up on 9 11 which of course all
moderate muslims would condem of course
muslims shouldn't be blamed for 9 11.
of course of course rule clip but the
world is very
unjust who is anja we know
the twin tower is unjust no what is
unjust is what is happening
in europe it's very unjust
what is happening in palestine is very
ironic okay first off that's like
don't worry about the twin tower don't
worry about the twin towers we have
nothing to do with it muslims have
nothing to do with it what's unjust is
everything else going on first off
that's a character what's unjust is that
that pubic little goatee he looks like
that character and saving silverman it
looks like a total like we would do in
cultural appropriation somewhere batman
is looking for him it's a parody so
again pity party as opposed to saying
hey we want to distance herself from
islam this has nothing to do with my
prophet
no that's not what they did well who do
they
think may have caused 911 these people
again era talk is on these people who
appear at the same conferences interview
each other support each other cross
promote each other
what do they want you to think really
occurred with 9 11 real clip
i know sometimes we feel you know who is
very happy when the twin tower
is being attacked who a group of jew is
so happy
in america they were having party when
they heard that the twin power is
has been burned they have a celebration
they have a party going on
what's so funny is this is with islam
it's just like sololinsky 101 they're
using the liberal tactics of accusing
jews of doing what clearly happened
across the islamic world
so 911 not don't worry about the twin
towers it's not unjust
not like palestine not like iraq and it
was the jews who were celebrating
muslims nothing to do with it i'm just
saying the jews were celebrating so
here's something else
this is not era but kamal salah talk
islam also appeared at the 2016
at the peak muslim conference which
hosted speakers again this is a guy
who's pushing for
moderate islam so you shouldn't be these
are the people with whom he's
associating do i am i saying that
it's one or the no no but we're building
a case here uh
at this exact same summit sallah
appeared alongside dr muhammad salah
there are two cases if a person entered
islam willingly or was born in islam
and is fully aware of the akira then he
accepted islam there is a general
consensus between the scholars that
had or the punishment for rinda is
execution
and by the way this is not something
unprecedented even today
in today's world secular
states have a similar punishment more or
less
in cases of somebody who they think that
he's a threat
to the society i'm going to go with less
kill people who leave muslims so again
this is let's let's let's
recap this here right away talk islam
works with era
iera they work together they both claim
credit for each other they both host
each other
and they both put on i'm assuming
funding these summits with all of these
muslim speakers
were either directly expressed by the
people in era
or talk islam or people that they have
hosted
have condoned wife beating have done
condoned killing adulterers
have condoned muhammad raping his
nine-year-old wife have said that 9 11
was not done by muslims and that the
jews were the ones celebrating
direct members of era have said get
these jews out of here stents are
clearly very anti-semitic
and at these events they did advocate
for
killing of anyone who leaves islam
nothing to do with my prophet when you
add this all up
is it all that surprising that talk
islam
era has had many of their members join
isis
five to be exact if we put a number on
it five
members of the organization have joined
isis
so talk islam nothing to do with my
prophet
we always this is a challenge issue to
you sir you're welcome to come on this
program
we always wondered why he refused to
flat out just condemn terrorist acts
you know what i mean just say this is
wrong horrible we need to reform islam
it's always
some generalized nothing to do with my
prophet uh you know spoken word awful
poetry this is just this is terrible
my profit was handsome but never really
any direct condemnation of these ideas
or policies
why because they support it they've gone
out of their way he supports it directly
at talk islam
era supports it directly or they
directly host people who advocate for
these policies here's the deal
like with clock boy like with care you
never have to dig that far
with any islamic organization to find
direct ties to terrorism
always from the from the the restaurant
that i used to go to at ann arbor
funneling money to hamas to care to now
era and talk islam
you cannot avoid it at a certain point
you have to say this isn't a small
minority when the people they're holding
out
as these moderate reformers are still
preaching and working with the people
who preach the same stuff do you have
any idea
how many degrees of separation you would
have to get you'd have to go through to
connect us to westboro baptists
who still haven't done anything this bad
they're all you couldn't do it
if you like this video and can't stand
the evil that is islam
subscribe i know we'll get letters right
but they're written in arabic so we
can't read them
or you can click one of these mystery
boxes or videos playing next to me who
knows what it'll be
could be a suicide bomber it's not a lot
on youtube
depends